when the walt disney company bought
marvel entertainment there was a lot of
skepticism about the acquisition on wall
street at the time wall street analysts
thought all of the best superheroes are
already taken i mean spider-man was
licensed to sony fox had the rights to
the x-men which is another one of its
popular comics and there was a great
deal of skepticism about whether this
four billion dollar transaction would
ever pay off for disney so we decided to
examine how much marvel is worth to
disney a dozen years after its
acquisition this is a number that disney
doesn't report so with the help of some
industry analysts we calculated its
current value to disney and we estimate
it's worth about 50 billion dollars
so disney is embarked on a strategy of
lining up major
entertainment franchises recognizing
early on that big name entertainment
brands would attract consumers at a time
when they're increasingly awash in all
kinds of viewing options disney's first
acquisition of pixar came right after
bob iger was named the ceo of the
company back in 2006 and his more recent
acquisition of star wars back in 2012
for 4 billion dollars roughly the same
amount of money it paid for marvel so we
took a look and compared the box office
performance for these franchises and
marvel fire outstrips either of the two
acquisitions so the 24 now 25 marvel
films have brought in excess of 22
billion dollars at the box office since
marvel studios began making these films
back in 2008. so that's an enormous cash
haul for disney now by comparison pixar
which is also an enormously successful
franchise for disney and it lives on
theme parks and it lives out in in
consumer products its box office tally
is around 15 billion dollars and star
wars shockingly is slightly yet less
it's around 11 billion
we estimate that sales of all these
marvel toys and marvel betting and all
things marvel have contributed roughly
10 billion dollars in licensing revenue
to disney since it acquired the marvel
asset more significantly as disney
launched its streaming service disney
plus it has increasingly relied on the
popularity of the marvel brand to
attract subscribers and we estimate it
accounts for roughly 20 percent or 22
of the 200 billion dollar value that
analysts have assigned to the streaming
service the popularity of shows like
loki or wandavision or falcon in the
winter soldier all have helped disney
attract subscribers to its streaming
service and once they're there
they can access other marvel films or
other marvel content it has been an
attractive war for new subscribers
disney's an amazing merchandising
machine and the films are just the
beginning of the way that disney
exploits its intellectual property the
characters that we see on screen will
live on in consumer products toys and
bedding and apparel and they'll also
live on in theme parks they will serve
as an attraction to get people to uh to
come to the parks disney has a very
sophisticated way to take its creative
output and find ways to bring revenue
across all of its various properties
so the next film due on its release
slate is the eternals which is scheduled
for release in november 5th disney was
likely watching the performance of shang
qi to see how it did at the box office
over a labor day weekend at a time when
the pandemic is surging and there was
some question about whether moviegoers
would actually return to the theaters to
watch this film it was released
exclusively in theaters before it is
available on other platforms like
streaming and movie broke domestic box
office records for labor day weekend it
brought in an estimated 90 million
dollars in the u.s and 146
million dollars globally which no doubt
sort of validates the decision to
release this movie into theaters and
will likely clear the path for the
eternals to be released theatrically in
november
[Music]
you